welcome to this new video by simply
learn in this video we will see top
Facebook marketing strategies for 2023
but before we begin consider subscribing
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
Facebook marketing is a form of digital
marketing that involves using Facebook's
advertising platform to promote a
product or service it involves creating
targeted ads that reach a specific
audience based on their demographic
interest and behavior advertisers can
choose from a range of AD formats that
includes image and video ads and can set
a specific goals for their campaign such
as driving website traffic or increasing
brand awareness Facebook also provides
tools for measuring the effectiveness of
a campaign loving advertisers track
metrics such as impression clicks and
conversions successful Facebook
marketing campaigns require careful
planning targeting and creative
execution digital marketers mainly use
Facebook ads as their core marketing
strategy to grow their business if you
are looking to be the one then simply
transpose graduate program in digital
marketing is the right choice for you
you will be benefited with a detailed
understanding of search engine
optimization content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website management and
optimization URL management search
psychology keyword organization and
match types keyword research Advanced ad
features and more not only these skills
but you will also learn the number of
tools like SC ranking HootSuite Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn YouTube Twitter
Google ads Keyword Planner and much more
so hurry up and find the course Link in
the description box for more details
avalanas have experienced youth success
in their career listen to their
experience find the simple learns course
reviews Link in the description box so
without any further Ado let's start by
knowing top Facebook marketing strategy
for 2023. today we're going to cover a
number of tips to help you gain a better
advantage on advertising on Facebook so
let's get right to it with tip number
one and with tip number one not all
advertisements need to sell something so
remember you have different objectives
on Facebook you can advertise an event
you can promote a customer story you can
send traffic to your website or you can
get them to download an app so it all
goes back to your objective so if we go
to Facebook and I want to create an ad
remember my first option is to create an
adjective so you have awareness you have
consideration you have conversion so
depending on what you want somebody to
do that's the objective you're going to
choose so just keep that in mind when
you're setting up your campaign on
Facebook you need to align your
objective with what you want people to
do tip number two we want to use
Facebook Messenger for advertising so
Facebook Messenger is a feature that can
be used with advertising on Facebook and
it's a good tool it's a good practice
because it'll allow you to as the
advertiser to commute with individuals
directly so it's a feature that you
should take advantage of because it
allows you to quickly engage with your
target audience so that's the beauty of
leveraging Facebook Messenger with your
advertising the communication tools
available and for you to engage with
your target audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have as
an on as an audience or prospective
client so you can can answer any
concerns they have right away so it's a
lot more personal and interactive than
other forms of advertising because
you're directly communicating with your
audience tip three use video
advertisements I can't stress this
enough video is very engaging in fact
it's not only engaging but it's very
easy to use so if we go to Facebook
really Facebook is telling us for video
all we need to do is have basically a
phone handy and an app and just to be
able to upload it so with Facebook video
you can really Drive awareness and you
can really Drive sales I mean you can
really make some really splashy videos
on Facebook all you need is a mobile
camera so with Facebook videos it's
really very easy to create you just got
to be creative that's really the key to
videos you know they're going to be
engaging to the end user say something
do something that's going to really grab
their attention and get them to do what
you want something to do so these are
just some of the examples you can see on
Facebook and you can see how creative
advertisers are getting you know clear
call to action great video or great
imagery good promotional use so there's
a lot you can do with video and really
make it interactive so I can't stress
video enough as an option for Facebook
it really is one of the better features
of Facebook advertising and really very
limited use of resources all you need is
that web camera an app and the ability
to upload that video that's really it
for video advertisements so keep in mind
and the reason why I'm harping on those
video ads is they tend to outperform
your traditional Facebook image ads and
other formats like the carousel or the
presentation mode so there's other types
of formats on Facebook video tends to
give it that extra Edge because it's
very interactive and in the form of
interactivity comes engagement so in
this example you know people are going
to react they're going to comment
they're going to share the video and
that's what you want as an Advertiser
you want to grab as much reach as
possible towards your target audience
and so video will help you do that it'll
help you not only engage with the person
but allow that video to be shared and
expand your reach towards your target
audience so remember video can range
from a few seconds all the way up to 120
minutes so you're really gonna get more
views regardless of how long the video
is because it's just going to be so
interactive so just keep that in mind it
doesn't have to be full on 120 Minutes
it could be you know anywhere from one
to five minutes you know to me that's
probably a good range but just know that
you have that lead way if you wanted to
so remember video ads always perform
better than single image ads or other
type of image ad formats on Facebook and
they also perform better when they have
subtitle support so just keep that in
mind as well because you may have you
know individuals watching the video from
you know different countries speaking
different languages say tip four when
you're placing your advertisement where
you place your advertising will play an
important role in deciding how many
people come across it so Facebook offers
a number of different options to choose
from so remember you get the news feed
you got instant articles right column
you got suggested videos so you got a
lot of options at your disposal there's
lots of other options too so you can
have Facebook actually automatically
place your ads or you can specifically
tell Facebook where you want to place
your ads and that's all part of the
Facebook setup so if we go to Facebook
and then we go to create your campaign
so if we close ad set here is where
we're going to be able to choose our
placement if we click on choose
placement we'll be able to you know be
able to allow Facebook to place it or we
can edit the placement specifically so
just keep that in mind you have a lot of
different options here again feeds and
stuff articles in-stream videos yeah
right com you even have Instagram so you
have a lot of options available to you
so my recommendation and Facebook's
recommendation is always go with the
auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're setting up your
campaign so start the advertising on the
news feed could be recommended the news
feed is where you're probably going to
get your most eyeballs most users spend
most of their time there and it has the
highest chance of grabbing their
attention so the news feed could be a
good place to start again you can have
it at Auto placement and your ads may be
there as well or you could specifically
choose just the news feed or other
placements so tip four just be careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you want to place your ad
where you're going to get eyeballs so
tip five Facebook ads also offer you the
option to advertise on Instagram so you
have that option available to you as I
mentioned in tip four you have the
option to advertise through stories
Carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all par part of the ad
setup when you go to choose your
placements here you got Instagram feed
you get Instagram stories and again with
both of those placements on Instagram
you can work with several different
types of ads including that Carousel ad
including that video ad so just keep
that in mind that Instagram is an option
for you take advantage of it there's a
lot more eyeballs on Instagram these
days and it plays off nicely with what
you're trying to do with Facebook so go
ahead and give it a try Okay so let's
take a quick break from the first few
tips we went over and let's take a look
at an ad so it's an ad break time so
let's take a look at this ad this is by
New Scientist and so what makes this ad
so great well there's been a lot of
shakeup in the world today about fake
news you know what is fake news so new
scientists is actually playing off of
that they're mentioning hey fake news
not in our world so they're actually
playing off off of that that term fake
news and so that's an attention grabber
so I think that's what makes this look
so good but this is a single image ad
and you can see here they're promoting
this ad with a promotion so try 12 weeks
for just 36 Euros okay so they have a
promotion in there so and you notice
they the image of the you know the
magazine they're also displaying that
hey you can look at this digitally on a
laptop a tablet or a mobile phone so you
have other options as well so they show
you that in the image which is placed on
the right side of their messaging so for
me this is a good ad because of the
placement of the image the type of image
they're using the play on fake news and
the promotion that they're offering up
so this is really a good ad it's very
eye-catching and hopefully the promotion
is good enough to get you to sign up
okay so tip number six so tip number six
we want to continuously do a b testing
you want to always have have this option
going for you you want to be able to
test variation a versus variation B
because you want to be able to find out
what works and what doesn't work with
your audience and on top of that it
helps you really put your best foot
forward by showing your best ad so by
doing a b testing you're getting
feedback from the audience and turning
that feedback into positive returns so
you're then turning your ad that does
work well in front of an audience and
you're going to continue to do that so A
B testing is always a good option so
remember when you're setting up your ad
in Facebook go ahead and choose to have
your A B test set up and when you do
that you choose that option you're going
to be able to then go in and choose what
it is you want to test without a and
then with ADD B so you're going to again
align your test with a Facebook page
you're going to choose an ad format once
you choose your ad format then you're
going to be able to go ahead and you
know put your ad in there there and then
you're going to choose your call to
action so the whole idea behind an A B
test is you want to be able to find what
it is you want to test is that going to
be the call to action is it going to be
the messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there are lots of things you
can test with Facebook on a b testing so
it's all part of the ad setup so things
you can change again are the color of
the elements Imaging text the call to
action the position of the ad there's
lots of things you could test that's all
part of the Facebook setup so the thing
is you want to continuously test that's
the key continuously test certain
elements of an ad so testing can be done
initially on broader elements and then
smaller finer details like statements in
your ad copy so my advice is when you're
actually setting this up on Facebook you
know think ahead think what it is you
want to choose to test my advice is
maybe start out with a call to action so
if you're in Facebook itself you know
you have an opportunity to test
different call to action try that that's
an easy way to test and then you know
when you test the call to action once
you find out what works and doesn't work
then you can move on to something more
sophisticated like maybe the image type
or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
the simply learn ad about hey learn how
SEO Works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interests it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know customers
in the buying process then that's our
objectives to get conversions then we
want to move somebody over to a product
page and get them to purchase you know
if it's focusing on just website visits
then maybe it's the objective of
consideration maybe you just want to get
people to your website to learn more
about your product so that's the whole
idea behind you know choosing uh the
right you know objective because you
want to align the objective with your ad
okay so tip number nine create
look-alike audiences and I'd like
lookalike audience because what Facebook
does is they create an audience that's
similar to the audience you already
advertising to or customer base you
already have so in other words Facebook
already has an idea of who your audience
is you you can also you know provide
them with additional information like an
email list to give them a better sense
of who your audience is and then what
Facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
Facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have and one example provide Facebook
with an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could Target so that's
the whole idea behind look-alike
audience it's a great feature by
Facebook definitely recommend taking
advantage of that why because it will
increase the number of people who will
find your advertisement relevant
remember you're targeting people who are
similar to your actual audience to your
the people who are already connected
with your brand or already liking your
page so if they're similar to those
people then the chances of them engaging
with you are going to be greater so
look-alike audiences tend to perform
well because you're targeting an
audience that's very similar to your
actual audience tip number 10 so use the
golden Point rule on your ad Creator so
what do we mean by Golden Point rule
well let's take this ad here as an
example so what we want to do is we want
to devote the creative into nine equally
sized boxes so what we want to do is
draw two horizontal lines and two
vertical lines just like a tic-tac-toe
box and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main subject of your ad in the
cross sections of the Drawn Lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there as a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden Point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's let's
take a look at another ad here on
Facebook and this one's my blue apron
and so of all the tips we've talked
about this particular ad takes into
account a lot of them okay so this is
again they're using multiple images in
this ad here so again what they're doing
promotion they're offering up a thirty
dollar off promotion here and what
they're asking you to do is sign up to
get that thirty dollar off so you can
see the call to action we already
mentioned that at one of our tips the
call to action matches the ad so they're
asking to sign up they're using really
good imagery here and they're supporting
that with you know some good copy and
text so this is what makes this ad so
good I mean who doesn't like good
looking food or tasty food and healthy
food okay so they're definitely taking
advantage of the imagery with a
promotion and with a good call to action
and so remember we want to a B test so
blue apron is likely testing this ad so
what they could do with this is test
different imagery or they could test a
different promotions so there's a lot
they can do here on the a b testing side
so for me if I were to test this yeah I
would probably be testing the imageries
because we want to be able to see what
images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so ideally there's a lot to do here from
the A B test standpoint and the way
they've structured this ad it makes it
very easy to test so that's what makes
this ad really good is shows good
imagery has a good promotion and aligns
the CTA tip number 11 so we want to
place the product in the right hand of
your creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the ad creative so here you can see
countdown of Black Friday this is an
Amazon related ad and you can see the
product is basically a litter box which
is placed on the right side so it's a
Black Friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20 percent text okay so you
want to use images that are clean
remember that blue apron image we looked
at and that was a very clean image of
food no text overlaying the image so we
want to try and stay away from images
that have text on the overlay okay so
there's no limit to how much text you
can add to your creative but you know
Facebook and myself recommend hey the
Lesser text you have the more likely it
is for your ad to have its desired
impact meaning somebody's going to click
on that ad okay so keep that in mind let
the image do the talking for you you
don't necessarily need to overwhelm the
image with words or messages tip number
13 so we want to use an ad creative
that's a tension grabbing and is
relevant for your business so again
going back to that blue apron ad hey who
doesn't like good looking food good
looking healthy food green food well
Switching gears we're looking at a Nike
ad who doesn't like a good looking shoe
here this is a good running shoe and
Nike is definitely taking advantage of
the opportunity to place the shoe
against a nice looking background so
here the image on the left you got a
nice mauve looking color the shoe on the
right on a nice red background to kind
of really play into the color of the
shoe and so that's attention grabbing so
the colors kind of match and go with one
another and it tends to grab your
attention so Nike's doing a good job
here I've just not showing an image of a
shoe really what they're doing is put
the shoe is a central focal point and
supporting that with additional color
and they're really putting the messaging
kind of as the background behind the
shoe so they're making it as a tension
grabbing as possible here the Nike's
done a good job with this ad you know me
personally I'm not the biggest Nike fan
when it comes to shoes but hey this ad
definitely grabbed my attention because
now I could see you know this shoe is
really popping to me we don't want to
use clip art in your ad creative okay
and don't use low resolution pixelated
images as well we want to use high
quality imagery so and use images that
are well lit you know natural lighting
always tends to work well as as well so
when you're doing a placement for
product whether that be food or shoe you
can see here in this plated example
they're putting it on the Right image
they're putting it in a natural
environment on a table on a plate with
some paper next to it you know and then
you could see from the one on the left
it's of a person holding a box with the
image of plated on it and so to me
that's not stock imagery or clip art you
know that's an actual person holding the
product so it's real life you want to
make it as real life as possible and as
clear and quality as possible so when
you create attention grabbing ads you
know show images of people benefiting
from your product instead of just having
the product itself so that's always a
good idea in the case of Coca-Cola you
know these people are enjoying their
bottle of Coca-Cola well going back to
the Nike ad you know they could have had
a person wearing that shoe or you know
running with that shoe that could have
been an alternative for them as well so
the whole idea is just make sure your
ads are attention getting and they grab
your attention and if you're going to
use people make sure the person's enjoy
enjoying it just like on the previous
image it's a person holding the Box we
could see she's got a smile on her face
and she is enjoying holding that box so
to me you want to use people with the
images to the best of your ability and
that means use that person who's
enjoying it so that's really going to
put the product in the Forefront okay
tip 14 don't hesitate to experiment with
your advertisements creative or its copy
okay so what do we mean by that really
we want to be refreshing our text we
want to be refreshing our images okay so
if you're going to place an ad on
Facebook don't let that be the only ad
okay if you're using a single image ad
you know feel free to change out that
single image from time to time
especially if a lot of people have seen
that ad so if you're using reach as your
objective and you're trying to reach as
many people as possible just keep in
mind that if that ad is reaching the
same people over and over again it's
going to get stale and you want to be
able to update that ad so feel free to
change out the imagery changing out the
text is just as easy okay so feel free
to play around with the text even if
you're not doing a b testing you can
always change out the text just to see
hey if changing out the text actually
gets you better engagement or meet your
goals tip 15 plan your campaigns for the
holiday season okay so can't State this
enough you know towards you know October
November December there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode so
advertisers are really pushing ads that
time of year especially Christmas you
know and people are accepting of that
because they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during Christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really really
take advantage of increasing your sales
and increasing your conversions so you
want to plan accordingly and so if
you're planning you know months in
advance you don't have to do a full year
but you know for me if I'm thinking I'm
going to do a lot of advertising during
the holiday season I'm probably going to
go out maybe once summer ends probably
August beginning of September beginning
of September seasons change a little I
might start thinking about the holiday
season and when you could plan
appropriately you can come out with
really good ads you can think about what
you want to say and so in this case you
know Target this particular ad is really
promoting Black Friday so Black Friday
is the day after Thanksgiving in the
United States and so here they're
letting you know Black Friday is here
there's deals to be had so planning in
advance this gives you an opportunity to
really really tweak your messaging and
come up with some good creative ideas so
let's take another break and let's look
at another good looking ad this example
we're going to look at Dell okay so Dell
I've seen their ads all over Facebook
they do a lot of different advertising
types between videos carousels again
this is a single image ad they're really
trying to do is get you over to the
storefront so you can buy one of these
good looking you know Dell computers
okay so you know here again they're
promoting their latest computer the Dell
Inspirion 3000 Series All in One desktop
so to them anytime they create a new
product they're going to go ahead and
pull out a new ad for that product and
here they're putting a little bit of a
Different Twist on it if you notice the
ad itself it's just the image of the
product there's really no promotion here
they're letting the product image speak
for itself they're really showing you
hey look how good this computer looks
you know this is our new model and you
know we got a shop now ctas if you're
interested go ahead and click on that
shop now so they're really putting the
effort into the image itself you know
they're not offering any promotion you
know no discounts you know what you see
is what you get with the image and you
click on it you're going to go right to
their storefront so Dell does a good job
of really you know cranking out their
new products whenever they go to market
so tip 16. shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
Target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody has seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website somebody's even
purchased from you before you have the
opportunity to reach back out to that
person so how often you reach out to
that person or how long between their
initial engagement and when you retarget
them really does depend on what it is
you're selling so if you're selling a
pair of shoes if you're Nike then
chances are somebody's looking for a
pair of shoes it's not going to be a
long purchase window meaning they're not
going to wait two three months so if I'm
Nike and somebody's seen my ad I'm
probably gonna Target that person in a
short period of time for retargeting so
it really depends on your product but
you don't want to wait too long between
the time they've been initially engaged
and the time you retarget so it really
depends on your product you know again
if you're selling merchandise you know
retail it's probably going to be a
smaller time frame if your Dell
computers you know that's a bigger
purchase somebody's going to take their
time so you know you want to Target
people you know for the hotel computer
probably you know over a longer period
of time okay so just keep the product in
mind you don't want to wait too long you
don't want to keep it too short so you
want to find that nice balance of when
you could retarget someone okay tip
number 17 keep altering the hook of your
ad copy what do we mean by altering the
hook so here you can see a couple of
different options option one you know
we're talking about hey if you're
interested in getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook hey start your
journey to get your DMC CA certification
so you know just altering the way you're
trying to talk to somebody is really
what we're after here on tip number 17.
you have an ad especially the text
remember we always want to refresh that
copy but if you're testing it try
different hooks try different ways to
talk to people okay it always works well
when you can have different types of
messaging because people react to
different messaging so an effective
strategy would be to create multiple ads
with different Hooks and see what
performs best so this is an option for a
b testing okay you have an option to add
messaging go ahead and talk one way and
one option and then you know tweak that
messaging tweak that hook a bit in
option b and see what resonates with
people so that's a good option for a b
testing is always you know look at the
way you're going to try and you know get
somebody to convert tip number 18 okay
respond to lead ad responses as soon as
possible so remember one of your ad
formats is a lead ad okay so if you have
a lead ad basically what you're asking
somebody to do is add their name their
phone number and their email if you get
that information don't sit on it react
to it just like the messaging the
Facebook Messenger how it's almost
instantaneous think of the lead ads the
same way okay you have somebody who's
engaging with your ad by providing
information you don't want to sit on it
you want to respond as soon as possible
in fact you know when you do engage with
that person let them know you're
available on Facebook Messenger so they
can actually then reach out to you via
Facebook Messenger just to expedite the
communication but when you get that
valuable information from the customer
you know respond as soon as possible
it's good customer service because the
longer you take to respond the less
likely the customer will want to
continue interacting with you so there's
no real good rule of thumb here except
for do it as soon as possible okay tip
number 19 add scarcity to your
advertisements so what do we mean by
that well in this example we could see
the top 100 registrations get free
access so by putting this into your ad
copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that there that they're not going to be
one of the first 100 registrations okay
so it allows you to really put some
sense of urgency in the ad to get
somebody to react so that's what we mean
by you know scarcity okay so by doing so
it could affect the long-term
credibility you know we don't want to
come across as fear-mongering by any
means but hey if your promotion is the
first 100 registrations get free access
then why not you know go ahead and put
it in there some other examples could be
you know only three days left to
register or first 50 get 50 off or you
know hurry now there's only two days
left so there's other language you can
put to play around with the language but
if you only have certain slots available
or certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevant scores so your ads do get
scored so the score ranges from one to
ten okay so what that score does is it's
an indicator to signify the quality and
engagement levels so you know if your
score is between one and six then the ad
isn't reaching the relevant audience and
your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your relevant score is
between seven and ten then your ads are
reaching the appropriate audience and
you're getting a lot of interaction so
keep an eye on that you know the lower
the number that means hey we're not gay
our ads not getting to the Right
audience and if it's not getting into
the Right audience our audience isn't
going to react to it so it all starts
with making sure you're reaching your
audience with your ad when your ad is
reaching your audience and you're doing
a b testing your audience is going to
react to one of those two ads so that's
always going to help your relevance
score so keep an eye on that relevant
score okay so let's take another break
here and let's take a look at an ad here
by Blue Bottle Coffee okay so I'm a big
coffee drinker myself I frequent blue
bottle in San Francisco a lot and so
here this is a nice image a nice
close-up image of coffee and I really
like this notice there's really no call
to action here okay so they're putting
their website URL the domain
bluebottlecoffee.com they're saying hey
we Source great coffees we roast them to
Perfection and get them to you fresh so
I can vouch for that really putting
their brand out there okay so this is
more of a brand awareness type app
that's their objective their objective
is if you're going to drink coffee at
some other location or with some other
brand hey take a look at ours you know
we got good coffee too we roast them
pretty good and and we make sure that
you get them fresh that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to introduce
their brand to you so this is a good
example of a brand awareness ad single
image ad they're definitely making use
of the added the image itself you know
with a nice close-up shot of that
roasted coffee so that's what makes the
this adds a special brand awareness you
know the image is telling us hey this
coffee looks pretty pretty good looks
nice and roasted it looks pretty fresh
and maybe I'll get Blue Bottle Coffee a
try so that's why they're putting their
domain there okay so it's a good brand
awareness ad and the hope is to convert
some people over to their brand okay so
tip number 21 include emojis in your ad
copy okay so emojis we know are popular
you use them in text use them on social
media I mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the case of Simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course with simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emojis support
that that message so you always get the
thumbs up it's a good Emoji you know the
image of the graduation you know that's
a good Emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun relevant
Emojis with your messaging it kind of
just helps it stick out a bit and people
resonate with Emojis and so it doesn't
hurt to add those emojis in your ad copy
and especially if your competition is
not using emojis you want every
Advantage you can to have your ad stick
out so emojis is a good way to get your
ad to stick out tip number 22 use UTM
parameters to your ad which can feed
into your Google analytics account and
provide tracking information so I can't
stress this enough if you're using
Google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use UTM parameters so
what do we mean by UTM parameters well
let me show you an example so all you
need to do is type in UTM tracking or
URL builder in Google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create UTM tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to average ties
and drive the audience to a specific
page in this case artificial
intelligence master's program page so
this is going to be the URL but we want
to append that URL with some UTM
tracking parameters our campaign Source
parameter we're going to put Facebook
because that's the source of what we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
Facebook is CPC which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name AI engineer to
identify what it is that campaign is
related to so notice that the only
required parameter is campaign Source in
this case we're going to put Facebook
but we can also use campaign content if
we want to different shade the different
ads that we have so you can use campaign
content parameter as well you don't have
to the only required parameters campaign
Source my recommendation go all
lowercase okay and then when you're done
you have a URL that you can use in your
advertising so when somebody actually
goes to that URL notice the URL includes
the UTM tracking and then analytics is
going to be able to pick up that
campaign from where Facebook the medium
is going to be CPC and the campaign in
this case is going to be AI engineer and
that's what you're going to look for in
Google analytics so it helps you track
your ads more closely because if you
don't use UTM tracking for example on
Facebook then analytics might you know
interpret that traffic coming from that
ad as you know organic social so we want
to be able to identify specifically the
campaign you're running by putting in
different variables for those parameters
so that's what UTM tracking is you want
to use it for all your Facebook
advertising okay so it really helps you
you know in analytics identify how your
campaign is performing not only is it
driving traffic but is the campaign
converting for you so if you're trying
to get somebody to sign up for fast then
analytics is going to help us measure
those conversions but with UTM tracking
we can bridge the gap between how many
people Facebook delivered or drove to
our site from the ad and how many of
those people actually converted so UTM
parameters help bridge that Gap tip 23
use exclusion marketing to improve your
Facebook return on investment by not
including people who have already taken
the action desired by you okay so this
is a very key feature here so if we've
already advertised and people have
reacted to our ad and has subscribed
they have subscribed then we don't want
to Target that person again so that's
what exclusion marketing is we want to
be able to you know Target people that
we're really after so if you know
somebody's looked at our ad and did not
convert or did not go to our website or
to not download something or whatever it
is we wanted them to do then those are
the people we wanted to focus focus in
on okay so in this case exclusion
marketing we're going to exclude people
who have subscribed in this case we're
going to retarget people meaning
advertise again to people who have not
subscribed so that's what the exclusion
marketing feature does it helps you
really hone in on where you're targeting
and retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24 track the right
metrics for your business so keep your
eye on important metrics what are those
metrics you know those are going to be
kpis kpis or key performance indicators
and kpis differentiate from metrics
because kpis are related to business
goals so track the right metrics for
your business what are the right metrics
for your business more than likely it's
going to be conversions or conversion
rate but you could be running a brand
awareness campaign just like a Blue
Bottle Coffee he did and so if you're
running a brand awareness campaign then
maybe your kpi or metric is going to be
a click okay or click-through rate how
many people are actually reacting to our
ad okay so you always want to align the
right metric with your business okay
it's just very important that you're
measuring against the right metric if
you're not then it's going to be
misaligned in terms of how you judge the
campaign performance another set of
metrics could be reach and frequency so
reach and frequency allow us to measure
how many people saw the ad and post
engagement can determine how many users
are reacting to your ads CPC helps us
determine the cost Effectiveness or how
much we're paying for every click you
could see that information in your
Facebook ad manager for example if I go
to Facebook's ads manager here I'm
looking at some some ads that we're
running here what can I see I could see
my reach how many people I'm actually
reaching the frequency in which they're
seeing my ad notice I can see my
relevancy score I can also see my cost
per result I can see the total clicks so
I have a whole set of metrics available
to me really what I want to do is pick
and choose the metrics that are most
important to the ad I'm running okay so
if it's reached am I reaching the full
amount of people possible if I'm running
a brand awareness campaign or it could
be some other metric like conversion so
we want to be able to align the right
metric with the right ad tip 25 take
advantage of Facebook's location
tracking tool for your advertisements so
Facebook allows us to advertise at up to
25 countries with different states
provinces cities districts and zip codes
so we can really hone in location wise
on where we want to Target so Facebook
allows us to do that so basically it
could be somebody in a particular area
or people who have been recently been
there or traveling to that location
Edition or actually live there so really
you can hone in on a specific location
based on certain set of criteria so with
this you could take your marketing to
the next level by approaching your
competitors customers by offering them
better discounts so that's the whole
idea targeting your advertising on a
specific location and then knowing that
your competitors are there you can
really put out some really good ads with
some really good offers to really
convert some of those people in that
audience okay let's take a a look at
another ad okay so grammarly this is an
ad that they've put out there and again
you notice there's no real true call to
action associated with the single image
ad here it's all about messaging here
they're saying hey download it free
today okay and so it's a browser
extension that they're promoting and
really they're trying to get you to
identify or identify with this
particular brand that offers specific
product so they do have a promotion in
there it's brand awareness hey your life
is about to change I mean the messaging
is pretty you know matter of fact
they're trying to get you to hey I need
this in my browser as an extension so
for me this ad is all about the
messaging here okay so with grammarly
you know if you're in Gmail or in word
you're an Outlook they got you covered
by using their browser expansion it's
free and by using it it's going to make
your life a lot easier so for me the ad
works from a messaging standpoint not
really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and we
can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention so here we wrap up this
topic on
marketing
strike 23
s video share it with your family and
friends and do not forget to subscribe
to Simply learn thanks for watching this
video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign